this is the luxury house experience
vibes I am this is super luxury I mean I
can't believe that they just built this
just for this experience I mean it's
kind of amazing
Fiji's partnered with American Express
to celebrate the launch of the new SPG
luxury card which offers great rewards
to Marriott and Starwood loyalist it's
kind of amazing because of all the
points you get back you know six times
your points for every dollar spent on
certain hotels and then three times for
certain restaurants and stuff so this
card is it's really awesome because all
the perks for being an Amex cardholder
pick up to another level what is your
like travel hack you're cheap oh my my
honest to goodness my best travel pack
is bringing a hot water bottle with you
on the plane like super cheap from the
drugstore if you bring it on the plane
and you get the flies in to fill it up
with like they're boiling hot water
which they always have and make their
hot teas and their coffee and it makes
every flight so comfortable it's like
cozy and comfy and you know it's
freezing inside a plane and now I do
that before the flight takes off and
I've always knows that they're always
surprised that I have it yeah I was
gonna say does anybody look at you weird
noise like well they look at it go we
don't and then once I get something like
this is smart
they don't yeah how do you treat
yourself when you travel I'd love to get
a great massage or a facial and if more
people want to experience how you
experience the world within this new
card then go to American Express comm
slash
luxury right right
[Music]